Allah herkese Merhabalar bir farklı
yaşamları farklı karakterler olan
sizleri Öncelikle saygıyla selamlıyorum
dediler ki Kırmızının dışına çıkma Ben
de dedim ki kırmızı benim kırmızı çirkin
ama bugün size esasında rengarenk bir su
yapacağım Farklı renkleri Hepimizin bir
hayatı Hepimizin bir yaşamı var ve
hayattaki farklılıklarımız bizi gerçek
biz yapan şeyler esasında kimse yaşamını
durgun Kimisi daha hareketli Kimisi
meraklı kimse umursamaz Yaşar Ama şöyle
bir gerçek var ki ben her zaman merak
ettim ve geleceği yağlayarak bir adım
atmaya çalıştım geleceği gençlerle
planlayarak
yeni bir vizyon katarak ve acaba
sonrasında neler yapabiliriz diye hep
hayal ettim
de biliyoruz ki yaşamda çok farklılıklar
var bugün buradaki topluluktan ben hiç
başarısız olmadım diye bilen var mı
zannediyor başarısızlık larımız ve
başarılarımız bizim Gerçek
zenginliklerimiz değil mi Bugün ben hep
kazandım diyen var mı monte ne demiş
kazanan olduğu yerde mutlaka bir de
kaybeden vardır zıpla hepimizin
içerisinde hayatın gerçeklerini de saklı
işte biz de bu başarıyı ve başarısızlığı
rengarenk çiçek bahçesi olarak
yorumlayabiliriz buranın teması yapbozlu
Ben bir araştırma yaparken çok çok ünlü
bir sihirbazı bekle at bir sihir ve
hayatın içine sığdırmış ve hayat temalı
bir yapboz yapmış Şimdi baktığımız zaman
şekilleri bir araya getirip işte bir
şekil aileyi bir şekil ekonomi bir şekil
farklı yaşamın güzelliklerini koyuyor
bir sihir içerisinde bunu çerçeve len
diyor ama bir zorluk olduğu zaman o
sihirli İçerisi sizin kuvvetiyle de
ve o çerçeve içerisine bu yaşamın
içerisinde sığdırmaya çalışıyor Sonra
yaptığım bazı araştırmalarda gördüm
Yetenek Sizsiniz'de de yeni bir
sihirbazlık kariyerine başlayacak işler
dahi bu uygulamaya çalışmış lütfen
umutsuzluğa kapılmayan Çünkü Hayatın
kendisi bir sihir değildir Eğer siz
sihirli güçlere sahipseniz zorluklarla
başa çıkabilirsiniz anlamına gelmesin bu
lütfen Çünkü ben böyle düşünmüyorum
Neden böyle düşünmüyorum rengarenk bir
ova görüyorsunuz karşımızda ağaçlarını
rengarenk çeşitlendirilmiş farklı
çiçekler olan bir ova ve bu Ova şunu
ifade edeyim çok çok yağışlı günler
sonrasında rengarenk çiçek açmış
Zorluklara rağmen hayatın problemlerine
rağmen inadına rağmen zorluklardan sonra
rengarenk bir yaşama bize esasında
temsil etmiyor mu buradaki rengarenk
çiçekler işte dizi gerçek Parti'yi
değil mi Senin çok güzel bir söz var
öldürmeyen acı beni güçlendirildi
gerçekten hayatın akışında çok farklı
insanlarla karşılaşabilirsiniz ki bende
karşılaştım İyiler olduğu gibi kültür
elde olabiliyor ama lütfen Biz ilk
alalım Bence en önemli vizyonu gerçek
anlamda yerlerin olacağına inanan
inandığı özellikle ifade etmek istiyorum
biraz önce bir ova gösterdim size ovabağ
meşhur Amik Ovası benim doğum büyüdüğüm
Topraklar olan Hatay'a ait bir olan daha
önce gördüğü kurtuldu ve şu anda verimli
topraklara sahip Antakya bir mi çok
tarih biten eminim birçok kişi gitmiştir
belki bugünden sonra gitme kararı
alacaktır medeniyetlerin bir arada
olduğu 17 ayrı medeniyetin Farklı
kültürlerle farklı insanlarla
birbirleriyle olan iletişimlerinin
kardeşlik sevgi ve hoşgörü içerisinde
olduğu bir şehir işte ben oralarda doğup
büyüdüm ve oradaki tüm vizyonu bundan
sonraki
bu çocukluğundan sonra hayatıma
aktarmaya çalıştım gelene Hoş geldin
denildiği gibi gidenede hoş geldiniz
dinlen bir şehir ama Özellikle
bugünlerde vurgulamak istediğim Bizimki
özelliğimiz daha var değerli dostlar
yiyorsunuz 1939 yılında Hatay Hatay
Atatürk ve silah arkadaşlarının mükemmel
bir diplomatik zaferiyle belki dünyada
eşine Ender rastlanır bir zaferiyle
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti nilhak olmuştur onu
yapan sadece idomatik bir zafer değil
orada yaşayan insanlar her görüşten her
dinden farklı kültürlerden Ben de orada
Hekim olmaya karar verdim ama hakim
olmaya karar verdiğim zaman diyordum ki
hacettepe'yi kazanırım orası en iyi ya
hacettepe'yi kazandıktan sonra dönerim
Antakya'ya muayenehane mi açarım Annemin
bana diğer örnek gösterdiği Doktorlar
gibi para kazanırım ama biliyor musunuz
Hayat hiçbir zaman Beklediğiniz bir
hafta öldünüz gibi olmuyor çünkü
karşınıza farklı fırsatlar far
bu çıkıyor işte o nedenle ben şu an
karşınızdayım İyi ki de O fırsatlar
veyahutta o kişiler Karşıma çıkmış Tıp
Fakültesi Eğitim sonrası üroloji
ihtisasını Ve tabiki akademik kariyer ne
kadar uzun değil mi ödüyorsunuz
akademisyenlik ölmüyor dolayısıyla da bu
kavramların tamamıyla farkına vararak
tıp fakültesinde çok önemli bir sözü
hiçbir zaman aklından çıkartmadı bir
hocamız bizi aynen şöyle hafide o burada
duruyordu diyordu ki arkadaşlar ilim
bilim derken filmi unutmayın diyor Ben
de dedim ki bu hocamız Neden bunu bu
şekilde söylüyor acaba sonra
öğrendiğimde hocamız eşini ve çocuğunu
bir trafik kazasında kaybetmiştir Evet o
gün anladım sadece Hekim olmak değil
hayata farklı bakış açılarıyla
bakabilmek daha geniş perspektiften
görebilmekte amaç Harvard bir öğretim
üyesinin bir profesörü tanımadığı o
çoklu zeka kavramlarının kendi içimize
sindirip onu da genç nesillere
aktarabilmek da hayat hayat sadece
O da zekalı düşünmek değildi
sosyalizasyonu da yusal zekayı da
geliştirmekte hayat ve farklı bakış
açılarından bakabilmek Hayat Ameliyat
sırasında en sıkıştığı anlarda
asistanlarına bir adım geriye çıkın tabi
hastayı bırakmayın Fakat daha geniş
düşüneceğiniz bir alan açın kendinize
demişimdir dolayısıyla da farklı bakış
açıları var benim kendi görüşüme göre
başarının hemen sıra olmuştu deyince
bugün Bu salonda gülümseme yen veyahutta
Cem Yılmaz'ın esprileri ile yağ euroluk
espriler de artık çok güzel en espriler
demeye kimse yoktur galiba benim
asistanlık yılların veya bitmeye yakın
dönemlerinde Cem Yılmaz'ın dinleyerek
Tabii ki Bizler bu eğitim sürecimiz
aktardı Tabii ki ben ruhları böyle sana
diyorum yani Hani espri sürekli olarak
komik şeyler üroloji harika tabii
gerçekten Mesleğimi seviyorum ama en
başta insanlara sevmeye çalışıyorum ve
bunun için uğraş veriyor Dolayısıyla
akademisyenliğin o kadar kolay
olmadığını daha iyi bir insandı
O kim olmak için şart olduğunu anladım
bazı önemli kriterler belirledim
hayatında uluslararasılaşma bugün
buradayız Ama eminim birçok kişinin
uluslararası farklı bir Network vardır
kendi mesleğiyle alakalı ikinci önemli
özellik bunu hiçbir zaman hayatımda
aklından çıkartmadı mutlaka ve mutlaka
tek bir işi yapmak kendi işinizle ilgili
farklı işlerde aynı anda sektör
yapabilmesi ve takip eden değil Biraz da
takip eder olmadı hani ben bakıyorum da
işte Avrupa'da Amerika'da bunlar olur
Ben de bir adım atayım onlarla beraber
geldim değildi yaptığımız çalışmalar
veya yapacağımız çalışmalar bu vizyonu
geliştirmektir Ben üroloji ihtisasını
sonrasında istedim ki bir bilim
doktorluğu sürecim olsun bunu nasıl
Anladım anatomi anabilim dalında bir
hocamıza gittim kulakları çınlasın şimdi
ya hocam ben anatomi doktorası yapmak
istiyorum dedim çok güzel olan aynı
zamanda o da güzel dedi ama diş unutma
dedi europool bir meslek ama anatomik
Op.Dr Dolayısıyla üroloji bana anatomi
birimlerini bir araya getirerek bazı
çalışmalar yapmaya gayret ettim farklı
bakış açılarıyla bakmaya çalıştım fakat
yaptığımız çalışmalarda şunu gördüm
bugün doğan bir kişinin ortalama yaşanır
artık yüzü x y z y ve z kuşaklarından
başlayacak yazıya kuşaklarından Bugünse
gösterdiğimiz bu kişi bilmediği kalp
içeriz çok genç bir Tıp Doktoru Ben ne
yapıyorum diye sordu ve araştırıldığı
zaman Medikal sülüs olduğunu anladı
orası olmuşlar 2050 yılında sağlık
teknolojilerini Sağlık Hizmetleri
geleceği ne olacak Lütfen bizi bu 140
karakterle birlikte tanımlar mısınız
Onun dediği 140 karakterden 22 konu
ifade etmek istiyorum teknoloji
kullanımda ustalaşmış Doktorlar bu bana
bir mesaj bizim Öğretim üyelerimizin
mesaj Demek ki resimlerimizi sağlık
teknolojilerini yönlendireceğiz daha
doğru çalışmalar yapmaya neydi her türlü
engelden almış bildi Biliyor musunuz Bir
Hekim olarak pek kimlerle konuşmayı çok
seviyorum ama
Bugün sizlerle konuşmayı top daha farklı
görebiliyorum çoğu zaman yapacağım
çalışmalara yapacağım teknolojik
uygulamalara Dolayısıyla bugün
bilmektedir ki 50 yıl sonra sağlıkla
alakalı konular konuşulduğunda sağlık
üretiminde bugün varolmayan yüzde
ellisinden fazla şirketlerin bugün ya
var olmamış ve hatta bugün sağlıkla
ilgilenmeyen firmaların yaptığı artık
biliyoruz çok farklı trendler gelişti
sağlığı oyun ulaştırmak sanal gerçeklik
artırılmış gerçeklik birçok farklı Yapay
Zeka uygulamaları ve akıllı hastaneler
bu yeni bir kavram Tıp lafı sürprizim
tıbbın geleceğini konuşuruz esasında
gelenekselci bir yapıya sahibiz Akademik
ve atıp eğitimcileri ve sağlık
eğitimcileri olarak Fakat artık
bilmektedir yere gereken bir şey var
Teknoloji artık bizim önümüze geçmemesi
lazım bir seçimler teknoloji yakalamamız
lazım Ama bir şartla insanla Hekim
arasındaki ilişkiyi mutlaka korumamız
gerekiyor o duygusu
var ya empatiyi bozmayacak şekliyle bunu
koymak gerekiyor Bu kim yapacak biliyor
musunuz tıp dışı Rise Benim öğrencilerim
sağlık teknolojilerini kendi hayatlarını
Entegre etmiş öğrencilerim hastalar
geldiği zaman bazen Hocam biz
hastalıkları Araştırdık Google'a bir
geldik diyorlar bakın teknolojinin bizim
biraz önümüzü geçtiği noktadır Bu
başladı Bir His Var istemiyorum ama bir
gerçek var işte biz bu çalışmalarımızı
artık biraz hızlandırdık diyebiliriz
benim sabit bir değildim ve gerçek
anlamda Tıp eğitiminde Tıpta Uzmanlık
eğitimi dahil tüm sağlık profesyonelleri
için önemli bir kavram olmuştur tuttum
füturizm Geleceğe yönelik tıpta Medical
uygulamalar Peki Bizler ne yaptık ben
pek Ben demeyi sevmem Çünkü gerçekten
çok genç bir ekibimiz var Hacettepe
Üniversitesi'nde ve Türkiye'nin farklı
yerlerinde
bu genç arkadaşlarımız da sağlık
teknolojilerinin özellikle sağlık
alanında Türk eğitimine Entegrasyonu ile
ilgili çalışmaları başladık Ama şunu
gördüm gençlerin bir beklentisi var o
beklenti şu daha iyi bir gelecek ve
farklılıkları yapabilme kapasitesi şöyle
bir bilgi vereyim size çok önemli farklı
ülkelerde yaklaşık kurulan son yıllarda
kurulan bir yaşında kullandılar toptan
yüzde 14'ünün öğrenciler tarafından
kurulduğunu biliyor muydunuz Peki biz
neden bunu ön görmemiz gerekiyor
Dolayısıyla bunların tamamı Bizim
Gençler yapacağımız çalışmaları dahil
oldu son bir buçuk yıl içinde bir ev süt
ile tanıştım fevkalade güzel çalışmalar
yapan gelecek araştırmalar enstitüsü'nü
vezirler ki hocam kim 32007 yılında
Ankara'nın sağlık durumu ne olacak ve
şunu gördüm Biz Hekim olabiliriz pek
Bulutlarda var ama teknologlar da bizsiz
Biz de teknologlar sız geleceği
planlamamız biraz zor o yüzden hadi gel
hep birlikte işbirliği yapalım
ve bu çalışmalarımızı kuvvetlendir elim
bir anatomi laboratuvarında hepimiz
sadece kadavraların olduğunu biliriz
değil mi Hayır yaptığımız çalışmalarda
is farklı uygulamaları sana gerçeklik
artırılmış gerçeklik 3D Medikal baskı
teknolojileri ne bugün ihtiyacı olan
kanal ve eksiği olan bölümleri acaba
ihtiyaçları nasıl karşılayabiliriz diye
yeni çözümler üretmeye başladı bunlarla
ilgili projeler yaptık bu projeleri yine
genç arkadaşlarımızla birlikte yaptık ve
bunun sonunda geliştirdiğimiz ve
binlerce öğrenci arkadaşımızla
Türkiye'den farklı uluslararası
alanlarda farklı ülkelerden eğitimler
verdi bu kutuların içerisinde organ var
ama gerçek organ değil ama gerçek
verilen harmanlanmış biri oradan üste
Medikal baskı teknolojisiyle bu
organların geliştirdiği sistemler ne bu
sistemleri bir Hekim adayı arkadaşım
deneye biliyor ameliyatını yapabiliyor
ne öğreniyor biliyor musunuz benim el
becerim müsait mi güzel Demek ki ben
O benim el becerim müsait değil
veyahutta bu konuda eksikleri var
Kendini geliştirebilir Peki mühendisi
arkadaşım öğreniyor Ben üreteceğim
cihazı nerede kullanacağım nasıl
geliştirebileceğim bana nasıl daha
farklı bir vizyon katabilir bu görmüş
olduğunuz birebir hastanın gerçek
verisinden harmanlanmış bir üniversite
modeli' bu bizim için çok önemliydi çok
farklı ve çalışmaları hep birlikte
gerçekleştirdik Avrupa üroloji sinin
Eğitimden sorumlu kuru beni davet et bu
modellerden onbir ayda istasyon
geliştirdik ve ben onlara bir şunu
yaptım aynı burada yaptığım gibi dedim
ki biz buradan 11-12 istasyon
gerçekleştireceğiz ve ben dedim Bunu bir
Türkiye'den gelmiş bir Türk Akademisi
onlara Avrupa göğsündeki sınavlarınızda
kullanılabilir Peki ama dedi Bunlar
hepsi yapamazsınız ki teker bir tanesini
yapsanız yeter fevkalâde oldu ama dün
sonunda şöyle ifade edelim biz yaklaşık
11 ayrı 12 hadis
de gerçekleştirdik Sonuç olarak hep
birlikte tüm ekip olarak bunları
paylaştığımız akademik çalışmalara da
imza attı ve özellikle şöyle ifade
edilmiş sanal gerçeklik uygulamaları 7.6
santimlik bir aydır ile ellerinizi
herhangi bir sistem varmadan kendi
etrafında uygulayabileceğiniz bazı
yazılımlar gelir o yazılımların esas
filmi Ben fark yemesek Tarih programı
Türk'ü olduğu için çalışmaların hepsi
Cemalettin ve Geleceğe yönelik çok daha
mutlu baktık Bir düşündünüz mü ameliyata
girmeden önce ameliyatla ilgili
planlamaya görebileceksiniz ve
ameliyatını bir soru yapacak Cerrah ne
yapacağınızı bir gün önce gösterecek ne
kadar güzel gelecek bunlar Birçok yerde
yapılmaya çalışılıyor En azından bir sen
çalışmalarımıza bunu
gerçekleştirebiliyoruz sana
ameliyathaneler sanal eğitim merkezleri
ve sana hasta modelleri ama kimlerle
beraber genç arkadaşlarımızla beraber
Bizler bir vizyon koyuyoruz o Vizyon
koyduğumuz arkadaşlar
Bu elleri hızlı yürekleri çok geniş
kalbi sevgi dolu kalpleriyle akıllara
arasındaki vicdanı muhakemeyi çok iyi
yapabilecek ama egolarını düşük bilgi
seviyeleri yükseltebilecek insanlar İşte
bizim görevimiz gerçek anlamda Bu son
haftalarda bir video izledim son
paylaşımları sizlerle yapmak istiyorum o
video beni çok etkiledi Duygu sevgi aşk
Bin Yıl Geçse de bir teknolojinin yerine
alamaz Sevgi aşk her türlü teknolojinin
önünde gelir biliyorsunuz çok önemli bir
sözümüz vardı insan eserleriyle Yaşar
ama bazı işler Eser bırakmayacak kadar
çocukluk çağlarından aramızdan geçerler
İşte bu videoda patır patır sanal
gerçeklik uygulamasıyla bir gün boyunca
yaşadığı bir an görüyorsunuz işte
teknoloji budur teknoloji insan
o duygusal her türlü ruhsal katkı
sağlayabilecek bir araştır ve tüm
unutmayalım ülke olarak akademisyenler
Farklı renkler burada toplanan Herkes ne
zaman ki zorda kalırsak umudumuzu
kaybedersek acaba biz bu teknolojik
ilerlemeleri gelecekte de başka
ülkelerin yaptığı gibi yapabilir miyiz
diye kendimize sorduğumuzda Lütfen bu
sözlere Aklımızdan çıkarmayalım bana ne
abone ol